the FBI is taking over the search for a
missing Wisconsin teenager whose parents
were found dead in the family's home an
Amber Alert is in effect for 13-year old
Jamie class police believe the only
child may have been kidnapped at
gunpoint
sheriff's deputies discovered the bodies
of James and Denise cloths early Monday
morning Adriana Diaz is outside the
family's home in Barron Wisconsin
investigators are struggling to find
leads they drowned a good morning good
morning when we were here late last
night police had a checkpoint set up on
the road here ask me if anybody had
information about what happened in the
house behind me police say Monday around
1:00 a.m. they received a mostly
inaudible 9-1-1 call the only word they
could make out with help when they
arrived they found Jamie's parents dead
and are now trying to find her when we
can find a 13 year old girl safe that's
our focus Barron County Sheriff Chris
Fitzgerald said Monday there are no
leads in the disappearance of 13 year
old Jamie cloths and the deaths of her
parents James and Denise Klaus
I've been doing this for over 20 years
and it's a crime scene like I I've seen
before but it's one you rarely see
investigators were in and out of the
class family home Monday removing
evidence police say Jamie is not a
suspect and may have been taken at
gunpoint the sheriff says a gun was
involved in her parents killings but
wouldn't confirm they were shot to death
scary you don't know what to expect
anymore no matter where your head people
in this small rural town are anxious for
Jamie's safe return we all have kids you
know we hopefully find her on Facebook
Jamie's mother Denise cloths shared
pictures of her daughter frequently last
year in a post for Jamie's birthday she
wrote Jamie's growing up to be the
sweetest and most kind-hearted girl love
you to the moon and back I'm hoping and
praying with God's help in the community
that we all rally around each other and
help find this girl and bring her home
the Barron County Sheriff says they're
using infrared technology and drones to
help in their search police all the way
in Miami say there was a potential
sighting of her there yesterday in a
black Ford Explorer with Wisconsin
plates they're asking anyone with
information to call 9-1-1 John Major
Anna and we hope those prayers are
answered